دمار لمنازل وأرواح المدنيين
خلال الأشهر القليلة الماضية ،
شهدنا فظائعًا في أوكرانيا.
قائد روسي محدد حتى الآن
يمكن لـ CNN أن يكشف حصريًا أن هذا الرجل
العقيد الجنرال ألكسندر جارافلوف
قائد المنطقة العسكرية الغربية
هو القائد المسؤول
عن هذه
الذخائر التي تستهدف المدنيين في
مدينة خاركيف شرق أوكرانيا ، وهي جريمة حرب
بموجب القانون الدولي ، يمكنك رؤية المزيد من
صواريخ المدفعية  من الواضح أنه يطلق النار
من الأراضي الروسية باتجاه
المنطقة التي أود أن أقولها حول اسمع ،
أعلم أنه يمكنك سماع هذا الآن ،
هذه هي بداية الحرب ، شاهد
المراسل الدولي الكبير في سي إن إن ،
فريد بليكين ، قصف
مدفعي من داخل روسيا داخل
منطقة جيروفلوف باتجاه مدينة
خاركيف  كان سام كايلي في خاركيف
وكو  عندما نسمع عن لحظات القصف لاحقًا ،
فقد نشعر بارتجاج المخ
على الزجاج الذي سرعان ما علمنا من
الخبراء أن هذه كانت صواريخ ذكية تم
بناؤها في أوائل الثمانينيات في نهاية
الحقبة السوفيتية.
من أسلحة روسيا
كما هو موضح هنا في هذا الفيلم الوثائقي الدعائي ،
هذا هو ما يمكنهم
إيصال
قنابل عنقودية بصاروخ واحد مبتسم
يطلق العديد من المتفجرات الصغيرة التي
تنثر القنابل ، مما
يضخم الدمار الذي تعرضت له
هذه الهجمات على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
في كل من هاكيف وكلاهما من نفس
اليوم  مثال واضح على
طبيعتها العشوائية عند استخدامها بهذه
الطريقة ضد المدنيين ،
تعتبر جريمة
حرب استخدام صواريخ السنافر هو المفتاح في
اكتشافنا لمن هو المسؤول
لأنها فريدة من نوعها لوحدة واحدة هنا قائد واحد
بعد شهور من العمل الجنائي يمكننا
الكشف عنها  سلسلة الأدلة التي أدت إلى
استخدام gerovlov لمقاطع الفيديو على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي لإرشادنا ،
نعود إلى بعض هذه الصور
تركزت الهجمات على 27 فبراير عندما
أصيبت ثلاثة أهداف مدنية
وثمانية أخرى في 28 فبراير بدأنا في
حي بافلوفا بولا في خاركيف ،
هذه شظايا من تلك الصواريخ
التي سقطت على زنبق حينا
يخبرنا أن
هذه الشظية تم العثور عليها في واحدة من  تأخذنا
الغرف
ليليا لرؤية صاروخ سنفور
سقط على بعد 200 ياردة من
مبنى شقتها في هذه المنطقة الغنية ذات يوم.
أتذكر صوت صفير
الصواريخ وأنا أعلم أن الصواريخ كانت
تحلق وأنهم كانوا مصحوبين
بطائرات مقاتلة أو طائرات بدون طيار يمكنك ذلك.  انظر إلى
الفتحة التي أتت من خلالها ، يمكنك أن
ترى الطريقة التي التوى بها الصاروخ عندما
اصطدم بالسيارة ، يمكنك أيضًا أن ترى بوضوح شديد
أن هذا لطخة ،
إنه ليس الصاروخ الوحيد القادم من
هذا الاتجاه في هذا اليوم على بعد أقل من
نصف ميل  الطريق ، ضربة أخرى
تساعدنا على تحديد موقع هذا الكشك الذي
يبرد الماء ، معالمه الرئيسية ،
الجثث هبطت هنا على هذا الطريق تلك
الأبواب الزرقاء التي تراها هي المكان الذي يوجد فيه
clus  شظية ذخيرة ثالثية
تم تصويرها في هذا الفيديو بعد لحظات من
الهجوم حيث قتل أربعة أشخاص من
بينهم طفل
قنابل عنقودية ذكية أخرى ،
ونحن نعلم ذلك لأن إحدى
القنابل غير المنفجرة تم العثور عليها على بعد 280
ياردة فقط.
2014.
هذا يؤكد أن هذه قنبلة عنقودية روسية
على بعد ميل ونصف ميلًا ، ضربة أخرى ،
المزيد من المعاناة وليس هناك ما يشير إلى أي
أهداف عسكرية مشروعة
كان الناس يصطفون في طوابير للحصول على الطعام ، ثم بدأ
شيء ما أصاب
الناس بالركض هنا ، كما تقول ،
هذه هي اللحظة بالضبط.  التأثير ، انظر
إليه مرة أخرى إطارًا بإطار ، يمكنك
رؤية حجم الصاروخ والقرب من
المدنيين الأبرياء ،
نحن هنا في خاركيف ، لاحظ
الضربات الخمس على طول هذا الخط من اليوم الثامن والعشرين ،
إنها إلى حد كبير في خط بعيدًا عن
ثلاثة هنا أي خط  حتى مع الزيارات
من 27 فبراير ، يمكننا تتبع هذه
الخطوط على بعد 24 ميلاً حتى نقطة التقاء
هنا عبر الحدود في روسيا
داخل جمهورية روسيا.  أنج من صاروخ smurge
حيث لدينا صورة قمر صناعي من
27 تظهر موقع الإطلاق
لاحظ عمود الدخان
وعلامات الاحتراق المنبثقة عن إطلاق smirch
هنا وهنا
بالتعاون مع مركز
مرونة المعلومات ، يمكننا أيضًا
إخبارك بمن  يطلق من هذا الموقع
لواء المدفعية الروسي رقم 79
من المنطقة العسكرية الغربية
المتاخمة
لأوكرانيا ويخضع لقيادة جرافالوف
وفقًا لمعلومات مفتوحة المصدر
راجعها خبراء عسكريون
ومصادر استخباراتية في سي إن إن ، وهم الوحدة الوحيدة
في هذه المنطقة المجهزة للانطلاق.
صواريخ سنفور
والقائد فقط لديه سلطة إصدار
أوامر لواء المدفعية 79
لإطلاق الصواريخ
وكان هذا فقط في اليومين اللذين
قمنا فيهما بتحليل هذه اللقطات التي تم مشاركتها
حصريًا مع CNN من قبل
المدعين العامين تظهر أن الأسلحة الروسية
تسود الموت من بينهم العديد من
خبراء بقايا اللطخة.  إن القول بأن هذا من بين
أعنف عمليات القصف في التاريخ الحديث
ليس غريباً  لهذه التكتيكات
الوحشية التي تستهدف المدنيين ،
فهي تشبه إلى حد بعيد ما رأيناه في
سوريا في عام 2016. لذلك لا ينبغي أن يكون
مفاجئًا أن غرافالف قاد أيضًا
القوات الروسية أثناء حصار حلب
، فهو مهندس الدمار
الذي تراه.  هنا
لتسوية حلب حصل على
أعلى وسام ممنوح
للضباط الروس بطل الاتحاد الروسي
لكن السوريين وثقوا جرائم الحرب التي
ارتكبها
بالروسية
رغم الخط المباشر من
الإفلات من العقاب الذي منحه العالم لروسيا في
سوريا للفظائع التي عانى منها
المدنيون هنا
اليوم السؤال  يبقى ما سيفعله العالم
لوقف هذه الدائرة